[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ne crains pas distant
nabila valoir éclater les ballons dans
lesquels il y à des frappes des chansons
de pascal obispo va percer des ballons
je vous donne la phrase le premier qui
sait à quelle chanson ça se rapporte
et là puis sur l'agent paul a chanté il
appuie sur le buzzer d'abord je donne la
main et celui qui a appuyé douala
chanter et à part qu'un point s'il a
vraiment la chanson c'est bien connu ce
magnifique navidad pas grave si vous
n'avez rien compris
que vous soyez centré sur le trampoline
oui valeo silencieux avant sinon on va
voir un accident
alors attention ont bondi je laisse
tomber la santé a rebondi mais rien
n'est trop là aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dimanche matin
le marine et blue sous le soleil bleu
marine et blanc ah oui c'est sous le
soleil rouge en bout ce lait
le baril
voilà mais la plus belle jusqu'à
d'oublier tout retard le poids des
lobbies paris ah oui mais je peux faire
des premières fois on l'a pas 10
c'est super ce que tu fais mais vise les
ballons quand même
[Applaudissements]
ah bah là bas là bas cette fois
david a servi comme ans edouard micon
non je n'ai pas bien je vais le gagner
la jurée pour ce bonheur en prime que tu
m'as dit josée bastien qui a toujours
qui est le témoin de produits s'allumer
initial parce que c'est quoi la chanson
millésime tum millésima plus belle année
pour ce bonheur en prime que tu m'as
donné je suis à jamais c'est ça être
peine la tête de ma mère qui a un truc
très bizarre
j'ai tué ma vie je regarde pas
[Applaudissements]
ma maison ma tour eiffel série quel bois
ouais je suis tombé pour elle on vous
écoute je suis ton raisonnement tous
car l'île aux oiseaux dessus des marches
[Rires]
l'existence et les roses se fane même à
lundi l'existence et l'hérault se fade
même à lundi n'existant pascal personne
ne te remplace ce nom perse et ouais
c'est pas c'est parce que
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]